you could use improvements in your sous
chef skills
okay hey everyone i'm jasmine and this
is my friend ben hi everybody i'm ben
mims i developed recipes for tasty food
network and now the la times i'm also a
former pastry chef today jasmine is
going to make a chocolate cake developed
by a real machine learning algorithm and
ben is going to make his own chocolate
cake recipe later our friend jerry's
going to taste them both to see which
one is better let's get started this is
charlie by the way charlie's making the
cake yes he's my good friend needs a
little help sometimes but don't we all i
guess it's time to get started charlie
give us a recipe for chocolate cake
red pepper charlie are you okay
do i think it'll taste good i don't
think it'll taste bad all right charlie
shall we get started let's see uh see
what kind of cooking chops you got did
you go to culinary school
neither did i first we're going to use
an electric mixer beet butter and two
cups of granulated sugar in a large bowl
until light and fluffy so we have two
and a quarter cups of sugar here divided
but you wrote to beat two cups
should i leave a quarter cup out of
this that looks like a good quarter cup
i'm gonna leave this and now we're just
going to beat this until it's light and
fluffy
it always feels weird to follow the
direction verbatim i'm so used to trying
to decode everything so this is my
chocolate cake recipe which i really
love because it's kind of an
old-fashioned cake recipe you know it
came from like the 80s and 70s so it
stands the test of time the way you get
started with it is actually with some
unsweetened chocolate so i'm gonna put
it into my saucepan with a full stick of
butter then i'm going to pour in a cup
of water now i know that water may seem
really weird ingredient to add into a
chocolate cake but this is going to add
all the moisture that you need i like to
use water just because it keeps the
focus on the chocolate i'm just going to
give this a stir until it fully melts
and then we'll take it off the heat and
let it cool for a few minutes so far it
feels like i'm making cookies but i'm
sure it'll turn out great i trust you
charlie we're good friends
all right this looks nice and fluffy now
we're gonna add in eggs one at a time
now we're gonna add in our vanilla so
the next part of making the cake is to
combine all my dry ingredients so i have
about two cups of flour the thing about
this recipe that's different is that it
uses a lot of baking soda and not baking
powder typically baking powder helps
things rise and like get really bubbly
while baking soda helps keep things flat
and we have some salt here just going to
whisk these two together make sure to
whisk it probably a good like 20 30
seconds just to make sure it's all
evenly combined so now the dry
ingredients are mixed we're gonna move
on to the wet ingredients all right this
looks good we're gonna set this to the
side and combine our dry ingredients so
i'm gonna sift together the flour cocoa
powder did you get cocoa powder or dark
cocoa powder
baking powder
baking soda and salt
oh my god yeah i love robots i was in a
robotics club for like maybe six years
all right what's next sift it together
i'd like to whisk it
to combine can i insert that into the
recipe or
or i can't i have to follow exactly
charlie add to butter mixture in three
additions alternately with buttermilk is
this lost in translation whatever
happened to the rest of the quarter cup
of sugar though are we gonna use this
again
even though this is not wet sugar is a
wet ingredient when it heats up it melts
then we're gonna add two eggs this next
ingredient is sour cream it's basically
like adding cream or more butter to it
but the sourness really helps to balance
sugar in the cake it reacts the baking
soda to help it rise it also kind of
balances chocolate which is also a
little acidic as well also i'm going to
add a little vanilla as well now i'm
just going to whisk these two together
and you basically just want to mix it
just until it's kind of emulsified it
kind of looks all like one now add the
melted cooled chocolate and butter to
the wet ingredients so once that's all
mixed together and again looks nice and
smooth now we're going to add our dry
ingredients and what you want to do here
is just kind of lightly sprinkle them
over the top and then i like to use a
whisk to mix my cake batter and it helps
to you know get rid of some of those
lumps and when you fold to which you
know i'm folding with a whisk here you
want to kind of scrape the outside and
then come up through the center while
you're turning the bowl in the other
direction as soon as you don't see any
dry patches mixed around you're done
there's gonna be a few lumps that's
completely fine start with
flour mixture i'm gonna add a little bit
of this i'm adding it but i'm not mixing
it in interesting okay now i have to add
in some buttermilk and then some more of
my flour mixture that wasn't mixed by
the way some more buttermilk and then
finally finishing with our flour mixture
so normally i would add in batches
mixing in between until combined to make
sure that everything is evenly
incorporated but that wasn't in the
direction so
he's a little old old model stir in
chopped pepper
okay i could do that interesting choice
with the pepper charlie this is how i
cut my peppers in at home i used to put
chilies into my smoothies and it's
supposed to give you like in the morning
so maybe that's what charlie wants to
happen when we have dessert so finally
we get to stir it in this is why we do
batches charlie so now we have our
batter mixed and i have two eight-inch
pans that have been greased and so i'm
going to divide the batter evenly
between them you know i have no idea how
that technology works but i feel like if
a robot creates a dish it's going to be
like maybe technically perfect but not
taste good because it doesn't have a
sole
and then i'll take my spatula and you do
want to make sure to just even out the
cake batter and so now we're going to
get these in the oven to bake at 350
degrees for about 30-35 minutes
this is quite thick but let's move on
divide batter evenly between pans okay i
got my buttered pans and they're lined
already and i'm gonna evenly divide
these i don't know if in the future i'll
use ai recipes but i'll give them the
benefit of the doubt one scoop it's like
so heavy too
i kind of feel like it's gonna have like
a cookie texture my batter is evenly
divided and i'm gonna go to the oven and
cook them for 35 minutes at 350. be
right back charlie come on charlie
i feel like having a robot in the
kitchen be really useful to have someone
there by your side yeah do you think
robots are going to like
uh haven't they already
so the next part of making the cake is
to actually make the frosting this is
just going to be a chocolate ganache so
to get started i'm actually gonna warm
up some cream so i'm gonna pour some in
a saucepan here i'm gonna put this over
medium heat once this comes up to uh to
a simmer i'm gonna pour it over the
chocolate we're gonna let that melt and
then we're gonna use that to frost our
cake and now when you pour the cream
onto the chocolate kind of want to take
the bowl just kind of shimmy it until
all that chocolate is just covered by
the cream then you're gonna let that sit
there for about one to two minutes to
let the cream kind of just gradually
melt the chocolate once this cools and
mix it together it's gonna be nice and
spreadable like a frosting cakes are in
the oven let's make the frosting
melt butter and chocolate in heavy small
saucepan so we're gonna start by melting
butter and chocolate in our saucepan
here and we're gonna stir frequently
until it's nice and melted next we're
going to add in our espresso powder and
chili flakes i'm wondering if charlie
did some skin and was like ooh spice
like maybe cinnamon nutmeg now we're
going to add in our espresso powder and
our chili flakes that's a lot of chili
flakes charlie have you had spicy
i have had spicy chocolate before and i
don't like it
do i like spicy chocolate no i think
it's disgusting
so now that the cream and chocolate have
been sitting here for about two minutes
what you want to do is not just start
whisking like crazy but you want to take
your whisk kind of stick it in the
center and just kind of barely move it
around you want to kind of really start
small movements and for a while you're
going to like nothing's happening and
then eventually you'll kind of see that
the chocolate and the cream kind of like
emulsify into one that's going to keep
doing this then you can kind of bring
your whisk to the outside kind of larger
strokes to really make sure you're
getting all that cream fully emulsified
into the chocolate there we go we're
going to let this cool down just for a
few minutes once it gets cool enough
then you know it's ready to use remove
from heat stir in vanilla tablespoon of
vanilla extract that seems like a lot i
think the frosting is gonna be
full of flavor vanilla is stirred in now
we're gonna transfer this mixture into a
large bowl now we're going to add in our
confectioners sugar and buttermilk all
right now we're going to use this
electric mixer and we're going to beat
the frosting until it's nice and smooth
step 5 place one cake layer okay great
let's bring back our cakes so now we've
let the ganache cool so it's really nice
and spreadable so now i'm going to
assemble the cakes together i always
like to take kind of my ugliest cake
which is this one and use that as the
bottom cake layer so i'm going to
eyeball maybe like a quarter to a third
of this ganache and you want to put it
on this first cake layer the ganache in
the middle is more or less acting like
the glue i'm going to take the second
cake layer and put this on top a little
more ganache if you've ever watched any
cooking or baking videos and you've
heard crumb coat that's what this is
start letting a little bit of the
ganache fall over the sides and as it
does take the spatula just kind of side
to side you're more or less wanting to
just seal the edges of the cake because
you're gonna pour more ganache over this
to make a really nice smooth layer i'm
gonna keep doing this until i have the
whole cake glazed all right cakes are
back i say cake loose sleep let's get to
decorating place one cake layer flat
side up on platter so we're gonna turn
one of the cake layers over which is
what we usually do for the top layer but
i guess this time charlie wants us to do
it for the bottom layer what's next
spread with one cup frosting okay i'm
gonna eyeball this the frosting is
spreading very well you can see the
chili flakes it's a little alarming but
it's fine top with second cake layer
flat side down spread remaining frosting
over top and sides of cake we can do
that there's lots of frosting left after
taking out these cakes i feel like
charlie's mad at me i'm liking the
texture of the frosting more than i'm
liking the texture of the cake that's
based on looks we'll find out about the
taste i don't think people are going to
use ai recipes in the future because i
think the food community is very keen on
developing recipes from the heart i just
feel like this cake recipe was made from
a place of sadness or anger well this
remaining frosting has been on the top
and the sides of the cake she looks
pretty good charlie
so now i've got the ganache all over the
cake got some like old-fashioned swoops
and swirls here and i really think our
taste testers are gonna like it i'm not
sure if our taste tester jerry will like
this but let's bring her in and see what
she thinks hi everyone i'm jerry and i
love chocolate cake moment of truth
let's bring them in
i think i'll start with this one first
and at first glance the texture looks
kind of moist but i like the frosting on
it
not too sweet which is exactly how i
like my cake velvety that frosting is
thick but very very good i like that a
lot slice number two it looks very dense
very decadent
that frosting's good it's a little bit
more rich i think this one's a lot more
moist and less sweet this one tastes a
little bit off just the frosting i think
when i had the cake it was a little bit
dry but then when i tried the frosting
it seemed a little it just i don't i
can't put my finger on it it just tastes
kind of off is this the chili flake in
it like legit right there perhaps is it
is there like a hot pepper in this thing
really that makes sense because i did
like taste a hint of spiciness you guys
got me
are you all ready to know which one i
chose yes i had to go with
this one
charlie i'm sorry i am curious though
and i would love to try it
cheers not bad a little dry but oh it's
kind of spicy mine's very like subtle
and the froth went out it's now it's
getting worse shall we try yours yes
let's do it i mean i already know what
tastes like so now i gotta hear what you
think
much more moist
and no chili heat for improvement
charlie interned but
that was it all right guys that was so
much fun thanks so much for watching if
you want to see any other foods leave
them in the comments and charlie we'll
get to them next time bye
oh yes
[Music]
you